[موسيقى]
من الصعب جدًا عمل ملف
تقليد جيد جدا ممتاز جدا
ممتاز بالطبع
ياخذ الكثير من الوقت
عليك أن تكون جادًا جدًا منتبهًا جدًا
[موسيقى]
دعوة إلى بومباي كرسبي رغم ذلك
بالطبع ثم داخل الصقر
ولذلك فإن رأي olaj غير منتظم في
فقاعات صغيرة وكبيرة وبعد ذلك
قبل كل شيء طعم معين هو أ
العدو الرطب
إنه سحر عندما يكون لديك هذا الذوق الصغير
مرحبا سيان قليلا حقا
[موسيقى]
كل عام هناك مسابقة البحر
تقليد باريس إنها مسابقة
صعب جدا لأنه
المنافسة التي هي الأكثر شهرة في
عالم المخابز و
المنافسة بالطبع من خبز كرواسون إلى
الشوكولاته ولكن أهم شيء هو
الرغيف الفرنسي
على وجه التحديد لأن الرغيف الفرنسي هو ما
الذي يمثل الرمز الفرنسي i
فاز في المنافسة على الأفضل
تقليد الرهان 2018 حتى الآن
الرئيس يأكل الخبز الذي أصنعه
كل يوم بالنسبة لي هو من دواعي سروري و
شرف
لذلك أذهب إلى هناك كل صباح
شخصيا لأنه بالنسبة لي هو كذلك
فخر
الآن فعل القيام بذلك
مذهل ولد والدي في تونس
في تونس نحب الخبز لأن
أنه مع كل طبق نحن مضطرون لتناول الطعام
بالخبز ثم في الثمانينيات
جاء إلى باريس تعلم القيام به
الخبز منذ أن كنت صغيرا منذ أن كنت
نشأت في المخبز استطعت
نرى أن الزوج كان لديه صعوبة في العثور عليه
في بداية المتدربين من الشباب الذين
كان الدافع وراء صداقته المتعبة
استيقظنا مبكرا وننتهي متأخرا كبرت
بجانبه ثم شيئًا فشيئًا
نقلت شغفه إلي وتمكنا أخيرًا
ربح ما يمكن رؤيته بفوزه بما
السعر خاصة أردت لوالدي
لأن والدي هنا يبلغان من العمر 30 عامًا
سنوات قضاها في العمل و
الجائزة بالنسبة لي هي الاعتراف
تجاههم مما علموني منه
كل ما عانوه منذ هنا
لقد قاموا بعمل مرهق
تضحيات كثيرة أنا هنا
فخور جدا
[موسيقى]